have you ever broken anyone's arm oh
yeah I mean the first first few
competitions because I was like you know
pretty athletic Grappler or athletic
wrestler going against like local black
belts and brown belts like my one of my
first matches I broke somebody at Kimora
um pretty much every time I've got a
heel hook which is only twice I've
broken an opponent
um if I have a joint lock it's probably
gonna break like a lot of times it
breaks before they attack yeah you see
like a really friendly fella how hard is
it to break an arm
or any break a joint well I don't think
it's that hard I think um like if you're
talking like about an arm bar we have
this position to where like people kind
of holding on holding on and then it
slips and their arm starts going and
then it just just breaks before they
even you know get a chance to tap
I love the sport and he bought a gun he
didn't tap one time and it was actually
it was surprising I had to put a lot of
force into that I suppose some shoulders
and the ligaments in the knees and
ankles but to fully this kid [__] kid
fully Let It Go and he tapped it I think
the angle is like up here they're built
different
hopefully he can be reconstructed yeah
all right
um what about a straight foot lock
you've ever
do you guys do straightfor locks at all
or no uh yeah I mean I'm learning them
now we had some kid come come into
practice one day and like [__] it with a
straightfor look straight for look just
this little like polish kidding footlock
everyone but he told the entire world
all these friends and family
we frankly put a hit on them in practice
and you just everybody
yeah it's always interesting when you
get like
yeah people that specialize can surprise
you that this could be effective stuff